Jason Statham apparently has a bit of a
different origin story than your typical
a-lister when speaking to Esquire the
crank actor opened up about how his
father taught him to hustle on the
London streets when he was just a
teenager saying not sit down outside of
Harrods and I'd pitch the jewelry and
what I'm selling is costume jewelry
basically but I'm selling it with a bit
of Street Theater and having a bit of
fun with it making a living an actor is
nothing if not a skilled salesman right
Statham went on to boast that he was
such a talented Hustler that he could
pull in as much as three thousand
dollars in a weekend so what did the
future Fast and Furious star say he'd
spend all that Dawan would buy cars and
with race cars I've always loved stay
film literally went from Hawking sketchy
Goods on street corners to starring and
Blockbuster action movies but throughout
it all the man's love for automobiles
has remained strong